I want to begin this video by reviewing
our definitions of the Union and
intersection after that I'll be
introducing two algebraic laws for sets
so the definition of a union B equals
set containing elements X such that X is
an element of a or X is an element of B
also a intersection B is defined as the
set containing elements X such that X is
an element of a and X is an element of B
so when I introduce the in impotant slaw
it should be clear that a union a equals
a because a union a is defined as the
set containing elements X such that X is
an element at a or X is an element of a
which should yield or you should see why
that equals the set a also a
intersection a equals the set containing
elements X such that X is an element of
a and X is an element of a which it
should also be clear why that is the set
a next we have our identity laws so
identity laws are laws where we have a
given set and we're performing an
operation on that set with a given
element these elements are the identity
elements so for this case we have the
null set and the universal set are
identity elements so a union null set
equals a and by definition that means
that a union null set equals the set
containing elements X such that X is an
element of a or X is an element of the
null set but since we know that the null
set is empty we can't possibly have any
elements in there so it's really saying
that a union the null set is equal to
the set containing elements X such that
X is an element of a or more simply it
equals a